Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous.
Merci de m’accueillir aujourd’hui
pour vous parler d’un sujet qui m’anime
depuis de nombreuses années :
l’importance d’oser se démarquer.
Autrement dit, l’importance
d’oser être authentique
et d’exprimer notre singularité.
Pour entrer dans le vif du sujet, je vais
vous parler un petit peu de mon histoire.
À 8 ans, j'ai rêvé que je savais faire
du vélo en marche arrière.
Du coup, le lendemain matin, au réveil,
qu’est-ce que je vais faire ?
Comme dans ce rêve nocturne,
je vais m’asseoir sur le guidon
prêt à partir en marche arrière.
Et là, qu’est-ce qu’il se passe ?
Premier coup de pédale.
Je suis certain que ça fonctionne.
Et là, patatras !
retour à la réalité.
Je découvre que le rêve ne fonctionne pas.
Mais je ne vais pas m’arrêter là.
J’ai vu dans ce rêve que c’était possible,
donc, qu’est-ce que je vais faire ?
Je vais persévérer,
m’entraîner, travailler
et après des mois de travail, je vais être
capable de rouler assis sur le guidon.
En 2000, j’ouvre le Guinness des records.
Qu’est-ce que je découvre ?
À ma grande surprise, je ne suis pas
le seul à rouler assis sur le guidon.
Il y a Matthew Poynter, un Canadien
qui a fait 50 km assis sur le guidon.
Qu’est-ce que je vais faire ?
Eh bien, je vais m’entraîner
et essayer de battre ce Canadien.
Et pour le Téléthon, en décembre 2001,
je vais faire 50 km en quatre minutes
de moins que le Canadien.
Et ainsi, à 13 ans, je deviens recordman
du monde du 50 km en marche arrière.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Là, vous pouvez vous demander :
« Mais à quoi ça sert tout ça ? »
Pour ma part, ça m’a ouvert
énormément de perspectives.
Suite à ça, je me suis beaucoup
intéressé à la psychologie,
je lisais des magazines scientifiques,
et donc, très logiquement,
pour l’université,
je me suis dirigé
vers des études de psychologie.
Et en parallèle, durant ces études,
j’ai rencontré Jonathan, un artiste de rue
qui va me former à l’art de rue.
Il y a un événement fondateur
qui m’a permis d’avoir un déclic
durant mes études.
C’était dans un amphithéâtre comme ici,
devant plus de 250 autres étudiants.
À un moment, j’ai une question,
je lève la main.
J’étais alors extrêmement timide.
Je perds mes moyens, ma gorge se noue,
mais ma curiosité dépassait
mon manque de confiance.
Du coup, j’ose lever la main,
je tremble, je pose ma question.
Une fois que l’enseignante m’a répondu,
je tourne la tête
et regarde comment réagissent
les gens autour
car j’étais certain qu’ils étaient
en train de se moquer de moi
et qu’ils avaient le regard rivé sur moi.
Je tourne la tête.
Qu’est-ce que je découvre ?
Personne ne me regarde.
Tout le monde était en train d'écouter
l'enseignante et sa réponse.
Là, j’ai eu une vraie révélation :
il pouvait y avoir un énorme décalage
entre ce que je vivais
intérieurement et la réalité.
Derrière, grâce à cet ami, Jonathan,
qui va me former à l’art de rue,
qui va me faire découvrir ce monde,
je vais comprendre la même chose :
dans la rue, si on est timide, quand on
tend le chapeau, rien ne tombe dedans.
On a besoin de sourire, de s’ouvrir.
On a besoin d’échanger,
de parler à tout le monde.
Et ça va me donner envie
de me lancer dans ce métier.
Une fois diplômé,
l’été suivant - l’été 2012 -
je vais dans le sud de la France
tendre mon chapeau après mes spectacles
d’équilibre sur un monocycle géant.
J’avais une girafe de 2m40 à la selle
et je jonglais à trois,
quatre, cinq, six balles.
Et ça va fonctionner,
ça va devenir mon métier.
Je vais faire plus de 250 spectacles,
je vais partir l’hiver en Australie -
c’est impossible d’être artiste de rue
en France durant l’hiver.
En revenant en France
pour la deuxième saison pour 2013,
qu’est-ce qui va se passer ?
Coup de théâtre !
Au mois de mai, je faisais
une promenade à moto dans Tours,
et je me fais renverser par une voiture.
Je prends le poids de ma moto
sur le genou gauche
et là, c’est fini.
Mes ambitions de saison
en équilibre sur ma girafe
s’effondrent instantanément.
Vous comprenez ?
Eh oui, c'est le jargon.
J’ai ma jambe bloquée dans une attelle.
Que va-t-il se passer ?
Je ne peux plus faire de monocycle.
Eh bien, je vais prendre mon vélo et je
vais essayer de continuer à en faire.
Je vais d’abord m’accrocher à la
pédale pour pouvoir tirer dessus
et au feu rouge, je vais m’entraîner
à tenir en équilibre sur mon vélo
avec une jambe tendue.
C’était très difficile, mais j’y arrivais
avec mes deux jambes,
alors pourquoi pas avec une seule jambe ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il va se passer ?
C’est parti, démonstration !
Est-ce que vous y croyez ?
Allez, concentration.
Exécution.
Au début, avant cet accident,
j’arrivais à tenir en équilibre
sur mon vélo comme ceci.
Suite à l'accident, je vais apprendre
à tenir sur une seule jambe.
Aux Championnats du monde
de coursiers à vélo -
j’y avais participé en 2011 - il y a une
épreuve d’équilibre statique à vélo :
on a tous un pignon fixe comme celui-ci,
un vélo sans freins, sans vitesses.
Je vais apprendre à tenir
en équilibre sur mon vélo.
Lors de cette épreuve, en 2013
à Lausanne, en Suisse,
après avoir retiré au bout de deux minutes
notre sac à dos de coursier,
notre casque et notre T-shirt -
on fait ce qu’on peut
pour attirer les coursières ! -
au bout de cinq minutes
en équilibre sur le vélo,
il fallait ôter les deux mains,
et au bout de six minutes,
il fallait ôter un pied.
On était 100 au départ de l’épreuve,
plus que 30 une fois
qu’il fallait lâcher les mains,
et au bout de six minutes,
quand il fallait ôter un pied,
le second, Andy Zalan, a tenu pendant
quatre secondes sur un seul pied,
et moi, j’ai réussi à tenir grâce à
cet accident plus de quatre secondes.
Yeah !
C’était chaud !
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Grâce à cette performance,
en 2013, je vais devenir champion
du monde d’équilibre statique à vélo.
Là, vous pouvez vous demander :
« Mais à quoi ça sert tout ça ? »
Ça va m'ouvrir énormément de perspectives.
Le jour où je décroche
ce titre de champion du monde,
je vais découvrir l’importance
d’accepter ce qu’on ne peut changer.
Il y a une étude,
qui a été publiée en 2016,
par des Britanniques, qui s’intéressait
à la longévité d’êtres humains,
notamment des centenaires.
Dans cette étude, ils interviewent Albert,
qui a 102 ans et qui dit :
« Si tu ne peux agir sur un élément,
inutile de t’en inquiéter. »
J’adore cette forme de sagesse.
Effectivement, si on essaie d’agir
contre ce qui ne peut bouger,
on va s’épuiser.
Je ne pouvais plus faire de monocycle,
j’ai essayé de faire autrement
et ça a fonctionné.
Aujourd’hui, j’interviens en entreprise,
des entreprises qui recherchent
plus d’efficacité, plus de performance.
Qu’est-ce qu’il va se passer ?
Souvent, on me dit : « Mes collaborateurs,
je veux qu’on développe leur bien-être
pour qu’ils soient plus performants. »
Je crois qu’on se trouve
entre la cause et l’effet.
Grâce à ce titre de champion du monde,
j’ai pu me rendre compte
que c’est souvent l’inverse :
on a besoin d’être performant
pour être bien dans sa peau.
On a besoin de réunir les conditions
de la performance dans nos entreprises
pour derrière nous sentir mieux,
améliorer notre fierté,
notre confiance en nous
et développer la cohésion d’équipe.
Suite à cette performance,
qu’est-ce que je me suis dit ?
« Je vais essayer de vivre de ma passion,
je vais essayer de vivre du vélo. »
Et quelques jours avant Noël,
il va y avoir un événement très marquant.
J'étais un soir comme un autre avec mon
meilleur ami d'enfance, Pierre-Marie.
On était face à la télé,
assis dans le canapé,
un soir tout à fait banal.
Il se tourne vers moi et me dit :
« Clément,
tout ce que tu entreprends réussit. »
Ça m’a scotché.
Imaginez que votre meilleur ami
vous dise ça cet après-midi,
« Tout ce que tu entreprends réussit. »
Qu’est-ce que, ce soir,
vous lanceriez comme projet ?
Qu’est-ce que vous feriez de différent ?
Cette question va me trotter
dans la tête pendant plusieurs jours
et le soir de Noël,
après le traditionnel repas familial,
je me retrouve face à mon ordinateur
et me fais une sorte d’auto-brainstorming.
Je vais noter des idées : voyage,
Cap Nord, rencontres, habitants, Norvège.
Et à un moment : « Eurêka !
Ça y est, je sais ce que je vais faire,
quel projet je vais monter :
je vais sonner chez l’habitant chaque soir
sur la route du Cap Nord
et offrir une démonstration
d’équilibre statique à vélo
contre une nuit au chaud. »
Vous y croyez ?
Tout de suite, le lendemain,
j’appelle mes copains.
Je leur souhaite un joyeux Noël,
je leur raconte cette idée.
Qu’est-ce qu’ils me disent ?
« Tu es fou, Clément,
jamais ça ne fonctionnera.
Déjà en France, c’est impossible,
alors à l’étranger, si tu ne parles pas
leur langue, n’essaie même pas. »
Je ne vais pas les écouter,
je me dis que jamais ils ne l’ont fait,
pourquoi écouterais-je des personnes
qui ne savent pas de quoi elles parlent ?
Et je vais aller chercher des sponsors.
La première entreprise où je vais sonner,
le dirigeant me dit :
« Tu peux revenir mardi ? Je regarde
ce week-end ton dossier de sponsoring
et on en reparle. »
M. Métais, un grand dirigeant d’entreprise
de ma ville natale, Châteaudun,
me reçoit dans son bureau
le mardi matin et me dit :
« Clément,
Je ne crois pas du tout à ton projet,
mais j’aime ta folie. Tiens ! »
Et il me donne mon premier chèque.
Waouh !
Imaginez ma fierté, ma satisfaction.
Et derrière, grâce à lui, je vais réussir
à convaincre 15 entreprises
et, en un mois, réussir à réunir les fonds
pour partir jusqu’au Cap Nord.
C’était chaud, là !
D’ailleurs - (Souffle)(Rit)
Il faut mettre plus fort
la clim, je crois.
Il y a un microclimat ici.
Je pars au Cap Nord, et, deux mois
jour pour jour après avoir eu l’idée,
le 24 février 2014,
je sonne aux maisons en Flandres.
Je viens de passer la frontière belge,
je prends mon vélo sur l’épaule à 17h,
je sonne aux maisons.
Première maison :
ils ne comprennent pas le français.
Deuxième maison : idem.
Troisième : idem.
C’était assez compliqué.
A la 8e maison,
il y a Marguerite, 84 ans,
qui m’ouvre sa porte
et me dit : « Bienvenue Clément. »
Pendant les quatre mois de ce périple,
chaque soir où je vais chercher des hôtes,
je vais réussir à trouver
une famille pour m’accueillir
et je vais ainsi dormir dans plus
de 40 maisons dans quinze pays.
Ça a fonctionné.
Qu’est-ce que je retiens
de cette aventure ?
Je retiens deux choses.
La première : c’est important
d’écouter des gens
qui sont déjà passés par le chemin
qu’on souhaite emprunter.
Malheureusement, parfois, on a
des projets où on est pionnier,
personne n’a jamais emprunté notre route.
Là, je crois que c’est essentiel
d’écouter sa voix intérieure
parce que malheureusement,
on va nous pousser en nous
disant que ça ne peut qu’échouer
alors que ce ne sont que des jugements.
Personne ne sait, en réalité.
On a besoin d’agir.
D’ailleurs, à ce sujet, Navi Radjou,
un Indien qui fait partie
des créateurs de l’esprit Jugaad,
l’innovation frugale -
L’esprit Jugaad, il le répète tout
le temps, c’est l’esprit McGyver,
le système D,
comment faire beaucoup avec rien.
Navi Radjou me disait,
un midi, il y a deux mois :
« Clément, tu vois le clip
‘Billie Jean’ de Michael Jackson,
où la lumière s’allume sous ses pieds ?
La vie, c’est comme ça.
Dans la vie, il faut agir,
il faut y aller.
Parfois, tu mets les pieds
à côté de la lumière,
mais ce n’est pas grave.
Grâce à une stratégie d’essais-erreurs,
tu vas légèrement modifier
ton choix, ta décision.
Et ainsi, tu vas pouvoir avancer
vers la lumière et vers la réussite. »
Je pense que c’est essentiel de se
souvenir de l’importance de l’action.
La réflexion, c’est important, mais
à un moment, il faut se jeter à l’eau.
La deuxième chose que je retiens
de ce voyage vers le Cap Nord,
c’est l’importance de se fixer
des objectifs ambitieux.
À l’origine, je voulais voyager
jusqu’au Cap Nord,
mais je ne trouvais pas de sponsor.
En rajoutant une difficulté - celle
d’essayer de dormir chez l’habitant -
j’ai amélioré l’attrait,
j’ai amélioré mes ambitions,
et j’ai réussi à attirer.
Et derrière, grâce à cette « folie »,
j'ai réussi à réunir 15 partenaires.
Donc, on voit l’importance de l’ambition
pour notre réussite.
Vous me voyez depuis tout à l’heure
en équilibre statique.
(Rit.)
Je crois que dans l'équilibre statique,
il n'y a que le nom qui est statique.
Parce que, je ne sais pas si vous
avez remarqué, mais je bouge beaucoup.
En fait, l’équilibre est dynamique.
J’ai pu le découvrir
en restant sur mon vélo.
Si je tourne autour du point
d’équilibre, ça fonctionne.
Si je m’arrête dessus, je tombe.
L’équilibre humain fonctionne comme ça :
on a besoin sans cesse
de peaufiner notre équilibre,
de connaître les leviers
sur lesquels on peut agir
pour justement réussir
à conserver l’équilibre.
Est-ce que, selon vous, c’est l’équilibre
le plus stable qui soit, celui-ci -
assis sur la selle,
les mains sur le guidon ?
Non ? Alors, quel est l’équilibre
le plus stable selon vous ?
Assis sur le guidon ?
Je vois qu’il y en a qui -
(Rit.)
qui sont inspirés.
Eh bien, tentons l’aventure !
Je me suis rendu compte
qu’avant les deux dernières années
qui nous ont beaucoup chamboulés,
on était, je crois, assis sur la selle
dans un équilibre qui nous semblait
hyper stable, hyper solide.
On savait qu’il y avait
quelques petites choses à régler,
mais on se disait qu’on pouvait
tenir encore quelques décennies.
Puis la pandémie nous est tombée dessus.
Je pense que ça, c’est une belle métaphore
pour montrer qu’on peut faire autrement,
même si, en apparence,
c’est totalement contre-intuitif.
Je vais essayer,
comme l’a suggéré monsieur,
de m’asseoir sur le guidon,
les pieds dans la roue avant,
et vous allez me dire
si ça paraît plus confortable.
Ce n’est pas certain.
(Rires)
Allez, on y croit !
Impeccable !
(Applaudissements)
Merci !
Je crois que c’est ça
qu’on est en train de traverser.
Effectivement, on a des événements
qui nous chamboulent.
Parfois on va poser le pied à terre,
parfois on va chuter,
mais ce qui est sûr, c’est que ça va
aider à changer de perspective
et ainsi, potentiellement,
à trouver un autre équilibre,
plus durable, plus pérenne.
Avant de terminer ce talk,
j’aimerais vous parler d’une anecdote
issue du monde du vélo.
Ce que je viens de présenter,
c’est un peu analogue à ce que Dick
Fosbury a fait en 1968 aux Jeux olympiques
où, au lieu de sauter en hauteur
face à la barre,
il est arrivé de côté
et a sauté dos à la barre.
Grâce à cette disruption,
à ce changement de perspective,
il est devenu champion olympique.
Aaron Gwin, en 2015, a réalisé quelque
chose d’assez extraordinaire, je trouve,
à la Coupe du monde de descente en VTT.
Qu’a-t-il fait ? Il s’élance en dernier.
Il est censé gagner, c’est le meilleur.
Au bout de dix mètres, que se passe-t-il ?
Il a donné quelques coups de pédale,
premier petit saut.
Il atterrit un peu fort : sa chaîne casse.
Imaginez sa déception. Waouh !
Il baisse la tête, il comprend
ce qui vient de se passer.
Qu’est-ce qu’il va décider ?
Il va donner le meilleur de lui-même.
Il arrive dans le premier virage,
il va arrondir,
il va avoir une fluidité dans ses gestes
très, très impressionnante.
Les commentateurs sont à fond
derrière lui.
Ils veulent voir ça.
Il va utiliser le relief, il va pomper,
il va essayer de faire de son mieux.
Au premier temps intermédiaire,
il est à moins d’une seconde du premier.
C’est dingue et il va continuer
avec sa souplesse, avec sa fluidité.
Il aborde la dernière partie
du parcours, la plus rapide.
Il prend la dernière bosse.
Il est à fond, la tête dans le guidon.
Il passe la ligne d'arrivée.
Et devinez.
L'incroyable s'est produit.
Il a 45 millièmes d'avance
sur le deuxième.
Il est sacré champion du monde,
sans chaîne.
Imaginez la tête du deuxième.
J'adore.
Je crois que c’est ça qu’on est
en train de vivre aujourd’hui.
Quel est le point commun
entre Aaron Gwin, Dick Fosbury
et mon pépin à moto qui m’a
permis de devenir champion du monde ?
Le point commun,
c’est le changement de perspective
qui nous a permis de faire la différence.
Et vous, comment est-ce que
vous pourriez vous démarquer ?
On voit ici l’importance dans la vie
de faire avec les imprévus.
Rien ne se passe jamais comme prévu,
il faut faire avec.
Il faut, comme Aaron Gwin, garder la foi,
s’appuyer sur nos atouts,
s’appuyer sur nos forces,
garder confiance.
À partir du moment où
on s’entoure de gens constructifs,
de gens qui croient en nous,
tout devient possible.
Soyez ambitieux, ayez des objectifs
qui soient très élevés.
Et enfin - on le voit
depuis tout à l’heure,
je fais du sur place -
je pense que c’est très important de temps
en temps de s’arrêter, de faire le point.
Qu’est-ce qui est le plus
essentiel pour vous ?
À partir de là,
vous serez capable, je crois,
de transformer vos pépins en pépites.
A vous de jouer !
Merci.
(Applaudissements)